I know that we have seen that there are two zeroes in this part of the graph,
but let's just pick one of them to focus us on. How about the right most one?
Which we knows in the interval 1 to 2. Now that we have chosen us here to focus
us on, we want to start narrowing down the interval that we knows the zero lies
between. In other words, we are going to start zooming in on this portion of
the graph. To do this, I'd like you to first pick a value of x that lies
between that interval, between 1 and 2. Type that here. And then, plug that
value of x into the function and write what f of x at your value is equal to.
Now, remembering that the function is negative when x equals 1. But it's
positive when x equals 2. Narrow down the interval in x in which the zero must
lie. So, the value of your function is negative, then the new interval will be
your x value and 2. But if the function is positive at your x value, then the
new interval will be between one and your value. Take a little time and think
carefully about this.